Speaker 1: OK, let's talk about the California
gubernatorial recall, the California gubernatorial
recall is today there are basically two possibilities,
either the don't recall that keep Gavin Newsom
side wins and Gavin Newsom remains the Democratic
governor of California, an overwhelmingly
Democratic state or or or the Remove Gavin
Newsom side wins.
And almost certainly an outrageous right wing
extremist named Larry Elder becomes the pro
Trump anti vax anti mask governor of California.
Really horrible stuff.
We'll get to how it's looking in a moment.
Last night, Joe Biden actually was in California
and he did an event in support of Gavin Newsom.
Ron Phillip Korski doing a great job with
his team, covering the riff raff outside the
event.
He has teams at all of these different events
filming.
Check out this just to give you the flavor
of what's going on.
This is just another argument between, you
know, there's a..
AXA's there's all sorts of wacky people showing
up.
And just listen to the arguments that are
taking place here.
If you can read
Speaker 4: the article, I read it and I just
don't get it wrong.
How do you know it's going to go up?
Speaker 1: Like, notice what's going on here?
There's two different arguments going on in
front of an F Joe Biden sign.
It's just complete and total chaos.
Speaker 4: I don't know.
Oh, my God.
Speaker 1: Why are you guys following the
disagreement here?
Speaker 4: I don't even know.
You know, it's not right now because I know
I want to have hundreds of.
In less than one year
Speaker 1: now, the audio glitch, but I think
Air Force mom unmasked Air Force mom is yelling
that there have been hundreds of thousands
of deaths from the vaccine.
Is that what she's saying, sweetheart?
Speaker 4: I have no idea how many people
die from the lack.
Aside from the reaction and when you looked
it
Speaker 1: out, he's saying more people died
from the vaccine than the flu, I guess
Speaker 4: where you are going to need it.
That's where you're brainwashed.
But not everybody dies.
Guys who come in.
Honey, I know everybody knows Kobe has a ninety
nine percent survival rate.
Why do I know?
Why do I can't you have an immune system?
I don't know
Speaker 1: why.
So that's Air Force Mom screaming.
They're the proud boys.
Also had a presence at this event.
This is a short clip.
If you're not watching.
The proud boys are, you know, walking with
a huge banner.
It's just all it's all nuts.
The banner says Free all political prisoners
now, which is a reference, basically, they're
saying free all of the rioters who were arrested
on January 6th.
They want those.
They want the insurrectionists freed.
Speaker 2: They saluting now, what are we
doing right?
Speaker 1: There's a police line now.
Someone just yelled communist's, they're.
And these are the last places I would because
it's just it's crazy.
Then they went back to Air Force Mom like
a while later and the argument was still going
on with active Air Force mom,
Speaker 4: you know, growing up to do your
research in order to get where you are here
in.
Going to work it out.
Speaker 1: So this is like, oh, my God, what
a sociological experiment.
So if you've just been listening to these
people arguing on the left, kind of like in
the background, you've got unmasked unvaccinated
Air Force mom telling a woman that more people
died from the vaccine than from the flu in
the last year.
That's, of course, not true.
Then in the foreground, you have another woman
saying that the Gavin Newsom, if Gavin Newsom
stays in, the taxes, will break California.
Now, remember, California has one of the most
dynamic economies in the world.
If California were a country, it would be
growing almost as quickly as many really quickly
growing developing nations.
There's a homelessness problem, without a
doubt.
It's not affordable for everyone.
But one of the things that makes places expensive
is demand.
People want to be there and it drives the
prices of things up.
So, too wacky arguments happening at the exact
same time.
Speaker 4: They have to do everything to prevent
illegal immigrants more rights than we do.
Speaker 1: Illegal immigrants have more rights
than.
So the xenophobia gets thrown into
Speaker 4: account even in.
No, I mean, I don't know how much I know
Speaker 1: it well, but how much do you make?
What percentage is that?
OK, so the important thing is the recall is
today, today, today, today.
If you haven't voted yet, you've got to vote
mail in that ballot.
The good news is that after in early August,
it was basically tied.
It was basically tied.
In early August, Gavin Newsom has built a
lead that is now 16 points.
Now, does that mean we don't vote?
Of course not.
It means you've got to go vote.
You've got to go vote.
Results are expected around 8:00 p.m. California
time tonight, tonight, 11:00 p.m. Eastern
time.
I will be streaming.
I will be streaming up until we get those
first results.
And I hope that you will join me, unfortunately,
unfortunately or maybe predictably, Larry
Elder, the Republican, the leading Republican
candidate, is not committed to accepting the
results if he loses.
Let's talk about that next.